so first I'm starting up up here on
resurrection tower and its really tall I
don't know if you can tell but it's
really tall but that's great because it
gives me a good vantage point for the
entire great plateau which is pretty but
that's not what we're here to look at
we're here to get some shrines so while
I'm up here I'm gonna actually Oh pull
out my chicest late and my scope and try
and play some pins so I know exactly
where I'm going to go this is going to
be super handy because this is just the
starting area but it's huge and I I tend
to wander I'm a known wanderer so I need
these pins to kind of help get me back
on track whenever I go after some
problems but I probably shouldn't have
so if we could pop into the map for a
second and just show folks exactly what
the distances between these two shrines
yeah so those two fries I'm up here so I
made them look pretty close together but
they're absolutely pretty far apart so
those those pins are going to come in
handy there's my first run and I'm not
supposed to have this yet but we are you
so I'm gonna jump using my handy
paraglider i'm going to soar to the
ground and head off to my first shrine
satisfy my gonna try and not run out of
stamina that would be kind of bad let's
do this link we're ready come on I can
make it almost that's pretty close
though that's pretty good
gonna go and see what this giant is all
about so what Elmo we chat a bit more
about what the significance of the
shrines is as far as by folks would
wanna hunt these out that's right so I
don't to give too much away but
basically if you beat the challenges in
the first four shrines you'll get you'll
get something which we'll see when we
get in at the end of this shrine and you
can exchange that for the paraglider
which I already have because I just
wanted to play around with it but
Hollywood Wally normally you're gonna
have to actually go through the trials
to get it and in the game at large again
I don't spoil anything for anyone but it
plays a larger part in the other game in
the full game now we're finally entering
the shrine i use my shika slayed it
verified that i am the hero so i'm going
to be able to get inside here and we're
mentioning to you just mentioned four
strains that have a special significance
but there are actually over 100 shrines
in this world there loads of them to
find and loads more goodies to so many
shrines so many shrines and dungeons and
there's just a lot to do in this game
we're just going to take a look at the
first couple here but there's a lot
especially actually thinking about how
people might approach playing this game
when they first head out in the plateau
depending on which direction they had
what they end up doing these might not
be the first to that folks run into what
they're playing the game but these are
definitely to the give you a really nice
introduction to what the shrines are all
about it's just like you said we're
calling them the first two shrines
that's because they're the first to you
probably should go to but this game is
really all about freedom and exploration
you can do anything pretty much in any
order that you want but we take a look
kind of like up and around because it is
a really cool looking place Israel
all kinds of shiny lights actually the
entry to her booth looks just like the
Lord is it recreated at annex what they
did with the constellation motif looks
like some metal slabs on the floor that
I can't do anything with just yet but
anybody who's been playing zelda knows
if you see something that looks like you
should be able to interact with it yet
but you can't wait you just wait now
what I just did is I found this little
platform here and i put my chicest late
in it and that's going to actually
update my chica slate with a brand-new
rune ability rune abilities allow link
to do all kinds of different cool things
not just in shrines not just in dungeons
but all around the world you can solve
puzzles you can find treasure chest you
can do all kinds of things this one here
we just got is the mcneese this room and
just like it probably sounds it's going
to let us actually have a magnet
likability we're gonna be able to pick
up and interact with metal objects so
we're gonna have some fun with this I
gotta say after seeing this updating my
devices feels kind of lackluster
honestly agreeing to our terms of
service agreements doesn't have the same
player is that why don't you let me do
stuff it's like the sheikah site allows
you to entry into here now you've got
all these special powers on it too it's
like the multi passes of multi passes
yeah I want to be able to put my phone
down just have this magic she just
update process happen as you can see
here I've activated the ability using l
and i can kind of see the things that
highlight is yellow those are things
that i can interact with so those big
metal plays that I couldn't do anything
with boom now I'm just throwing them
around like they're nothing the power
link is drunk with power maybe that's
just me so I got his out of the way no
boom I can actually enter the shrine and
see what's going on
yes I feel kind of mayhem we can do with
this and this is just again we've
already looked around but this is a
really cool-looking shrine it's just
really really particular up and see I
can't get past this big wall of stones
but luckily one of them is made of metal
so it stands no chance against me in my
back beats this rune so talk a bit more
about how it is that you're controlling
his house so I music like I said I
activated the ability with L and I can
actually he's the control to move the
thing that I've grabbed around and im
gonna go when i use the metal block to
block this guy's attack instead actually
really powerful he could do some real
damage to me bukan so i actually oh oh
no any new I'm not going to push you
with the water yeah you don't like that
do you drop that on your face but I
think of him he doesn't drop some
goodies it's wishing that that's one way
to deal with that enemy but other
players might find different ways to
it's really interesting to see how you
tackle the different puzzles and that's
what this game is all about the way I
play is not the way that anybody else
that I've seen blaze gonna play really
it's just all about choice and freedom
so again we've walked across this metal
slate here but that's not going to help
me get across this big big gap so I'm
gonna have to use our puzzle solving
abilities and
lift up this metal plate and create a
little bridge for myself out gently
gently boom now we can get across and
look at that have two shiny shiny
treasure chests we're not just gonna
pass that by oh no no no come to me show
me you notice it could have even grab
that and then use that to you can just
cause all kinds of mayhem with the mech
e sister and it's pretty great ya gotta
bow now she's one thing that folks might
have been wondering when we solved that
puzzle to get across that gap is maybe
why we didn't just climb that wall why
is that a problem for us but the
structure of the shrines makes climbing
around little tricky that's true they
knew that we would be trying climbing
everything so a lot of these walls are
really smooth so we can't actually kind
of them that's why he's gonna have to
hey I told you to open stay open don't
make me get mad okay so we finally made
it it's to the end of this dungeon and
look it's a mysterious dude let's talk
to him im sue DS got to say and you may
have noticed there was a mysterious
voice speaking to us at the beginning of
the shrine that was him he set up this
trial he's been watching me causing
mayhem with this room this whole time so
so he just saw you steal treasure he did
he told that with it though just raided
it home like opened everything destroyed
everything broke his pet robot there so
the guardian he's just been waiting for
someone to cause mayhem it's so lonely
in here
though to be fair he looks like he's
been waiting a really long time very
long time probably entertainment at that
point is me looks gorgeous though he
clearly moisturizes let's be real but
now he's telling me that he's the one
who set up this trial basically and to
reward me for solving it not only do I
get this cool night nice is rude he's
actually going to give me a spirit or
the spirit orb if I collect four of them
it's what I can exchange to the old man
for the paraglider which I already have
bahaha but as I said you collect them
throughout the game from all of the
other shrines and they serve a different
purpose in the full game Chuck Haley
looked a little bigger trustworthy he's
like what is loose it's not every day
not every day you have a spirit orb
absorbed into you seriously I'm
impressed with how this guy has this
pose master serials